hi everybody I'm a Tony Kushner I'm uh
thank you
co-chair with Ambassador Jean Kennedy
Smith the Board of Governors of the
Edward M Kennedy prize this is the sixth
time we've gathered to present the
Edward M Kennedy Prize for drama
inspired by American history the prize
was established by ambassador Jean
Kennedy Smith to honor her brother the
late great senator from Massachusetts to
encourage American playwrights theater
composers lyricists and librettists to
use the stage as a platform for
exploring our country's complex history
and the ways that our past informs our
present and will shape our future at
this moment when grotesque unprecedented
an ever widening economic inequality
threatens not only the American
democratic experiment but the life of
the planet at this moment when the
plutocracy and the kleptocracy have
merged in a naked unapologetic
for-profit demolition of our
institutions of government and our
barbaric bad mood this morning and a
barbaric I was its the stormy Daniels
disappointment thing I was like really
that's all okay anyway a barbaric
desecration of every principle of civic
good and a wholesale troduce of the
reality principle itself at this moment
when the ego anarchists and canting
hypocrites of the unprecedented ly
unhinged right are busily noisily
distracting the national attention
trying to make us forget the past 38
years of catastrophic political
misadventure that have led us to today
to the edge of the abyss what better
moment than this to award the Edward M
kennedy prize to a play that asks us to
remember that the path to our current
collective insanity was blazed by the
unmediated emancipated financial sector
I'm very pleased to be welcoming
everyone to join us in celebrating a
remarkable engaged outraged and
courageous playwright Ayad Akhtar and
his thrilling important play junk which
is the perfect title for the kokuto
peein world it depicts in its genesis
the perfect title for a play about an
addiction to a drug in this case
money and power that turns humans into
lotus-eaters into wealth junkies of one
kind or another and is the perfectly in
app title for a beautifully wrought
entertainment that is the absolute
opposite of the toxic trash it brings to
blistering dramatic life so I want to so
first of all I'm gonna I want to say a
couple of words of thanks to Mandy
Michelle Hackett who is on the board on
the Kennedy prize board the smartest
thing I ever did was asking Mandy should
join the board and Mandy together with
an Thor in the Columbia library and
Allyson Morrow and Anne mesquita have
organized the entire thing today
i flaked out this year completely and so
I feel enormous ly guilty but also
hugely grateful to Anne announcin and
Anna mesquita and Mandy for pulling us
all together and now here's how we do
this thing every year we have a film
about the life of senator Ted Kennedy
jeans brother then we have an actual
Kennedy Ted Kennedy jr. who gets up and
showers the room with Kennedy magic
no pressure just you know I I'm sure you
remembered to bring the Kennedy magic
and then because one of the things we've
learned over the years about Senator
Kennedy is that he was a huge musical
theater queen really and and and love
musical theater more than any else so in
his honor we always ask a star of the
Broadway and musical theater world to
come and entertain us
and tonight we're incredibly excited to
have the brilliant michael service who
will get up and sing so when the guy
gets up here in sings you know that was
Michael service after that we always had
a little bit of substance because one of
the ideas in creating this prize was to
forge a connection between the world of
theatre and the world of both serious
inquiry into politics and a serious
examination scholarly examination of the
American past so we always ask scholar
whose work interfaces with the play to
come and speak to us in today they were
really really thrilled to have Columbia
professor and Pulitzer Prize winning
journalist James Stewart who's going to
explain the entire financial structure
to us in
mere minutes and if anybody could
possibly do it mr. professor Stewart
could do it after that uh because this
is a prize awarded not to playwright or
musical theater composer and lyricist
and librettist but to a work we're going
to have a selection from the Prize
winning play junk performed by the very
very great Steven Pasquale who was in
the original production at Lincoln
Center and then I had it's going to come
up with me and Ted and get his prize so
I'm going to sit in the film is first so
here we go that which we are we are one
equal temper of heroic hearts and will
to strive to seek to find and not to
yield for all those whose cares have
been are concerned the work goes on
the cause indoors the hope still lives
and the dream shall never die
[Applause]
[Music]
no matter who writes the history books
when people look back on this century
they will say that Edward Kennedy was
one of the ablest and most productive
most compassionate and most effective
men who served in the United States
Senate in the entire history of the
country my father loved this country and
was fascinated by the men and women who
helped to shape its history whenever he
felt the need to better understand an
issue he often looked back to how others
had solved similar problems
[Music]
he loved historical documents and
biographies their perspective helped him
gain understanding not only of their
time but of our own Abe Lincoln was a
quiet and a melancholy man but when he
spoke of democracy this is what he said
he said as I would not be a slave so I
would not be a monster this expresses my
idea of democracy
whatever differs from this to the extent
of the difference is no democracy
my grandmother Rose Fitzgerald Kennedy
gave tours of her home in Hyannis Port
yeah it's a very charming little picture
of Ted with his father at the Embassy
looking very serious who and a wonderful
round of the president's late President
Roosevelt a tradition my father followed
giving tours of his office like Grandma
he could narrate our nation's history
from an extraordinary point of view my
father wanted to make history come alive
he created the annual family history
camping trip
he packed up all of my cousins and took
us on trips to visit famous American
sites in the company of historians a
senator Kennedy has been taking his
nieces and nephews and many of his
family to historic places
year after year it's a wonderful family
tradition it ought to be a family
tradition everywhere because those trips
can change your life he took us to
Plymouth in the south shore the homes of
Nathaniel Hawthorne in Herman Melville
in the Berkshires Paul Revere and
Longfellow house the Freedom Trail the
USS Constitution the Brooklyn Bridge
Harpers Ferry Manassas Mount Vernon Fort
McHenry and a church in Richmond after
senator Kennedy's most recent visit
we're Patrick Henry made his famous
speech
Ted nearly tackled me on the Senate
floor the next week to tell me about it
and how exciting it it was to him and
and to the members of his family he
can't insist that every child is going
to develop a love of history or an
understanding but we sure can do
everything we can to give an opportunity
for the young people his love of
American history and his place in it is
treasured by our family but his
contributions to celebrating and
preserving our history is his lasting
gift to all Americans my brother Edward
Moore Kennedy was the last of my mother
and father's nine children
right from the start he captured our
attention my mother had an insatiable
interest in history literature in the
arts and she taught and quizzed each of
us about what she thought was important
mother required Teddy to memorize the
poem the midnight ride of Paul Revere
she felt that longfellows poem was a
wonderful way for her children to learn
about poetry and history at the same
time listen my children and you shall
hear of the midnight ride of Paul Revere
on the 18th of April in 75 hardly a man
is now alive who remembers that famous
day and year teddy always said that
early exposure to our nation's history
and literature had an immeasurable
impact on his life an avid reader of
biographies he or third his own true
compass as well as several others
including a children's book and how laws
are made as told through the eyes of his
beloved dog splash he admired the visual
arts and was an accomplished painter who
shared his work with friends and family
music was perhaps dearest to him a gift
from our grandfather honey Fitz and our
mother Ted as you know singing sweet
Adeline I used to play for him on this
piano
[Music]
[Applause]
Teddy and I shared an enjoyment of
theater
[Music]
especially for him musical theater he
admired the discipline and skilled a
theater demanded of actors directors and
writers he was intrigued by the theaters
creation of worlds based on the human
imagination either for the purposes of
escaping what's difficult in life or for
the purposes of confronting difficult
truths he loved the creative community
and the feeling was mutual
he was an ardent student of American
history and of course he devoted his
life to public service for over 40 years
in the United States Senate he
championed the role of the arts the
humanities and the promotion of our
culture life is integral to the American
experience
Teddy could have done anything with his
life and so he chose to do everything we
are all the better for it
hello everyone I'm Ted Kennedy jr. and
I'm so pleased that so many of you could
make it here this afternoon to honor an
incredible playwright and this year's
winner of the Edward M Kennedy prize for
drama
inspired by American history to you Ayad
Akhtar thank you and congratulations
[Applause]
I love watching that film year after
year because my father was he was an
incredibly hard-working and serious man
who took his job very seriously and put
his whole heart into this nation but he
also was very playful and I think this
that this video really shows his
personality comes out and I also just
wanted to recognize my family who's here
tonight this afternoon
my wife Kiki and my daughter Kylie who's
kylie is actually a graduate student
here at Columbia University getting her
PhD in physics so it's great to be here
[Applause]
it's great to be here at the Columbia
University campus so junk is a
fast-paced electrifying an insightful
depiction of our country's allure and
some would say obsession with money and
high finance during the go-go days of
Wall Street in the 1980s a theme that in
many ways continues to this day
junk bonds allowed our society to feast
on excess and it portrays our culture's
intoxication with greed and wealth
accumulation and how our culture was
able to suspend and forget honest and
ethical business practices to me this
play really asks us to question two
conflicting values in in our history
individual self-interest and the right
to pursue happiness versus our
collective responsibility to each other
it's a classic depiction of how our
country's history and culture is
conveyed and through artistic expression
which is why junk is the perfect
recipient for the Edward M Kennedy prize
I want to thank the selection committee
for recognizing this amazing and
provocative playwright among the very
accomplished group of finalists
I want to thank Columbia University for
hosting us here today and for of course
administering this prize
I want to thank Tony Kushner the
spiritual leader of this award Tony
thank you for all that you do year after
year to keep this prize alive and to and
to encourage future playwrights to
tackle some of our most pressing issues
that we face in our country I want to
thank all of you here today for coming
and of course I add I want to thank you
for bringing American history to life
your play takes us out of our comfort
zone stretches the understanding of the
American experience and it makes history
fun interesting and accessible which is
exactly what we need art to do as my as
it was said in this video the purpose of
this prize is to encourage people people
that are maybe new to history even new
to the theater to develop a love of
history
- Jamie Wyeth thank you for this
incredible work of art and in this work
of art which we will award to this
year's winner in a few minutes is really
depicts my father's life of the sea and
the ocean and his beloved sailboat the
Maya sailing through the waves with a
magical sunset really capturing my
father's and life and everything and his
spirit and Jaime thank you so much for
your presence here today but most of all
I want to thank my Aunt Jean I did speak
to her earlier this afternoon she wasn't
feeling well but she asked me to convey
her thanks and appreciation to every
single person here and my my aunt she
know you should no one had more fun with
my father than my Aunt Jean you know my
father's known as the Lion of the Senate
the voice of the powerlessness powerless
the supporter of the NEA and arts
education in our schools a fighter for
social justice and thanks to my Aunt
Jean he will always be he will also be
remembered as an artist and as a
historian who desperately wanted to make
art and history accessible to students
and new audiences who never knew they
liked history dad loves spending time
with his artists friends who were such
great company and would help him keep
things into perspective and remind him
about the important things in life and
he loved the camaraderie and the
friendship he shared with many artists
and they loved him and his camaraderie
too so I just want to say thank you
again so much to my aunt Jean who shared
such an incredible special bond brother
and sister Lee bond and love for each
other and I'm so grateful that Jean
decided to create this honor in my
father's name in such a special way so
again I just want to say on behalf of
the entire Kennedy family thank you so
much for coming here this afternoon and
thank you to an incredible work of art
that we're here to recognize and
celebrate
[Applause]
hello you know it's only a banjo so
tuning it really won't make any
difference so he'll just go right on I'm
Michael service this is Jill McGinty
from the losers lounge I I couldn't be
more more honored to be a part of of the
events today this this prize is such an
extraordinary prize and and the
commitment of the Kennedy family to the
Arts and to America is unquestioned I ah
display is is makes makes a villain like
Mack the Knife seem downright quaint so
we're going to do a little Mack the
Knife Oh the Shaw has pretty teeth did
he shows them pearly white just a jack
knife has make--the deer and he keeps it
out of sight when the shark fights
with his teeth dear scarlet bill knows
start to spread fancy gloves though
where's Maddie so there's not a trace of
red on the sidewalk Sunday morning Liza
body losing life someone sneaking round
the corner is that song
[Music]
from Fatah the ring
of cement bags dropping down the cements
just for the wait he's disappeared to
draw out his cash and Mackey spends like
a sailor
did our Mackey do something rash
Sukey tawdry gently driving verse Polly
Peachum
[Music]
Lucy Brown oh the life forms on the
right dear
now that my he's back in town
[Music]
[Applause]
well these are all very hard act to
follow
I'm James Stewart I'm a professor at the
journalism school here and I'm also the
author of den of thieves and I was I was
very intrigued and I have to say
somewhat flattered when I read early
Press reports about junk that I had the
author had read den of thieves and along
with some other works had inspired this
particular work but it also made me a
very picky observer when I went to the
play I'm just saying the first maybe ten
or fifteen minutes I was very caught up
in the amusing exercise of assigning the
real-life characters to the fictional
characters in the play and they are very
real-life I have to say even though some
of them are still denying that they have
any bear any resemblance to the
characters in the play and the Stevens
character in particular is very close to
the actual Michael Milken who was the
great junk bond financier who dominated
the the scandal in the 1980s I think
it's particularly appropriate that this
prize is honouring something that it's
taken from history because I think now
with 35 in almost 40 years of
perspective on those events we can see
that what happened on Wall Street in the
1980s was a very pivotal moment in both
economic and political history in this
country I think we can look back over
American history and see that there have
been periodic times and certain figures
in the business world effected profound
change on American society certainly the
the robber barons the great fortunes of
the late 19th century marked the
transformation of the country from a
primary agric into a manufacturing
economy and the 1980s I like to think of
as a similar transformation of the
trends of the manufacturing economy to
what I like to call the thinking economy
which continues to this day
jump bonds were essentially an
intellectual concept they were an art of
what now is known as financial
engineering they took no raw material
whatsoever
they took computers and a mastery of
intricacies of financial calculation the
junk bond of the ninth
were simply transformed into the
collateralized debt obligations of 2008
which bear a remarkable resemblance to
what happened in the 1980s and the after
of shocks were still grappling with
today but I think I as genius was to see
the inherent drama in this story some of
which I tried to capture in the book but
which he brilliantly transformed the
stage because after my initial trying to
put names on the characters I find
myself I found myself completely swept
up in the drama of his play and the
sweeping themes that he managed to
capture and about two hours of
performance time one of those certainly
is a pretty traditional literary trope
which is money corrupts and money
certainly did corrupt in this case and I
was impressed that he he he doesn't cut
any corners in clearly depicting milk
and as the criminal that he turned out
to be he pleaded guilty to six felonies
and was sentenced to ten years in prison
at the same time there was a complexity
of the Milken character that he also
captured in which I think has made many
observers of the play a little bit
uncomfortable which is what great drama
I think manages to do like so many
things in American life today the
character of milk and they're extremely
polarized views there is a sort of
libertarian free-market following that
he's still commands which thought he was
a great genius who was unfairly
persecuted by people who were envious of
his wealth and then there is another
group and I guess I would put myself in
that category that found that
essentially he was he was a criminal he
may have been brilliant and a genius and
much of what he created had merit at the
same time he knew no boundaries he had
no respect for the law he thought he was
above the law and he committed many more
felonies in my view than he actually
pleaded guilty to but if money corrupts
I think junk the play makes clear that
money also levels it can revolutionize
money is coldly objective which
may not provide much emotional support
but it is blind to prejudice it is blind
to the cruelty of others it's blind to
institutions that have outlived their
usefulness
what really freaked many people out
about Milken is that he and the Empire
the financial empire he created
threatened the existing economic and
social order in America it threatened
the elites of the time which were those
large blue-chip corporations they're
entrenched leadership which by the way
reflected almost no diversity in the CEO
Swedes before I was a journalist I
worked at a what was known as a
white-shoe law firm on Wall Street and I
can recall that the summer outings not
all that long ago were held at a Long
Island Country Club that did not have
any Jewish members and there were many
barriers not just Jews but needless to
say people who also did not come up from
acceptable backgrounds starting with
African Americans who were completely
unrepresented in the world that Milken
was challenging and I think John
captures that side of him it almost
makes Milken out to be an early
globalist somebody who recognized that
human life as a human life that can be
enhanced through financial techniques in
some cases so I think John ended up not
being the staff to either camp Milken
was clearly depicted as a criminal and
at the same time he was reflected as a
force for change changed in many cases
that was long overdue and I think today
when we look at the increasing
disparities in wealth in this country
the great accumulations of wealth in
recent years the social unrest that has
triggered the Envy's of elites today
many of which seem like closed
opportunities that many Americans are
excluded from and the continuing
upheavals as we move away I think
inevitably from a manufacturing economy
the message of John seems to me more
relevant even than it was
in the 1980s so I think I'm here tonight
because I think this is a great play
it's a great message it's important
theme
I hope thanks to this prize it will get
many many more productions and will get
people thinking more deeply about the
kind of society we live in thank you
[Applause]
hi everybody
I'm Steve Pasqual thanks for having me
I'm very excited for ed and his
brilliant play junk I'm one of the very
few actors on planet earth who can say
that he's worked on a new play with Ed
actor and a new play with Tony Kushner
and so for me having them sitting next
to each other tonight is a special kind
of joy in small world although I think
there's a danger in the ozone layer
above their brain power possibly having
an issue at some point I'm you're gonna
hear a speech from the top of Act two
the characters Robert Merkin and he is
addressing a roomful of investors and
influencers at an annual investment
conference I believe that's about all
you need to know and in true actor form
the day we closed this play all the
words went out of my head so I'll be
reading most of his past few weeks the
news the papers have been filled with
nasty words about a pending deal that
all of us in this room have been
watching pretty closely
Saratoga McDaniels ongoing bid for
eversince steel a deal which of course
was financed by the money that many of
you put up now reading seeing some of
these pieces on the news you'd think we
were like locusts come upon the land I
mean all these idyllic images of
small-town American life workers coming
through the gates hard hats lunchboxes
fathers the fathers we're told we'll be
out of a job
busy Peterman has his way we're told
that sacker Lowell and yours truly are
using financial wizardry to destroy the
values that made this nation great for
the locusts not well the frogs can't be
far behind right well I don't agree with
any of that what is wrong in America
right now and there is definitely
something wrong has nothing to do with
corporate debt I mean all the
fear-mongering around this deal all the
waxing poetic about the death of America
Manufacturing I sometimes feel like I've
stepped into a collective delusion the
bizarre self-serving belief that we
Americans are somehow better than others
that american-made is better whether
it's American steel or American cars or
televisions or whatever no evidence is
offered just nostalgic rhetoric about
what our fathers sacrificed and how
great they were and how we here in this
very room are endangering the legacy
they left behind you marry all this
Norman Rockwell sentimentality with the
nasty xenophobic tirades about slink
eyed Asians copying our stuff and the
dirty spics taking our jobs and you
begin to get a picture of what is
actually wrong with this country today
there is a blindness out there right now
and it is not the blindness of those who
see nothing but dollar signs no it is
the blindness of a nation unwilling to
question itself unwilling to learn from
the evidence of the marketplace because
see the marketplace is telling us that
our steel isn't as desirable as steel
made in China
it isn't as cheap as quickly produced or
superior in any way same with our cars
our appliances our electronics the
Japanese are making all of these things
more cheaply and better that's the truth
Honda is a better car that's why I Drive
one but what are we here in this country
we're Americans we invented the
automobile we built the greatest steel
mills the world has ever known
god bless america why don't we set aside
the revolting assumption that God
doesn't bless other nations or that
somehow an American father's job is more
important to his family than a Chinese
father's job is to his let us set aside
those lies those delusions and stick
with the facts fact they are winning
fact we need to change
fact when you stay blind you can't
change and when you can't change you die
and that is what is happening in this
country right now thank you
[Applause]
so so the Kennedy prize is chosen by
secret network of nominators they are
actually secret no one except us knows
who they are so they can't receive
bribes or death threats 20 people who
work in the theater around the country
who send in ballots weighted ballots
every year in September and October
nominating plays and musicals and then
the plays and musicals the five top
ranking plays and musicals are judged by
a panel of distinguished judges this
year the distinguished judges were Carol
Becker Dean of Columbia University
School of the Arts
Gabriel Kahana songwriter Steven
Levinson playwright Kate Moreau Ryan
Ryan playwright James Shapiro Larry
Miller professor of English and
comparative literature and the godfather
of this prize in maan Zuri composer
Christopher Diaz playwright and educator
Mona Mansoor playwright Seamus Khan
professor of sociology chair of
sociology special advisory reach of the
vice president for arts and sciences of
Columbia University and this panel of
incredibly distinguished judges chose
junk by ahead Akhtar I'll read their
citation John takes on the vexed
question of inequity dividing American
society it trenchant Lee examines the
financial behavior and the flawed system
of thought in the 1980s that paved the
way for the polarized world in which we
now live Manufacturing debt in doing so
it speaks directly to the aims of the
prize and listing theatres power to
explore America's past and through that
speak to our present so crucial to the
health of our democracy so I had please
come up
so the prize consists of two things this
is the actual prize with print of a
gorgeous painting made for the prize by
the great artist Jamie Wyeth is here
with us today of Ted said his father's
beautiful sailboat and also the bursary
part of the award which is a check for
$100,000
[Applause]
I I really don't know how to respond to
all of this I'm very moved
it's very moved by that film very moved
by the surpassing genius of Tony
Kushner's oratory which is so effortless
and it's blistering blistering
brilliance so I have written out some
words that I'd like to read here and
begin with thank you for this incredible
honor I am so grateful to the nominators
the jury the board to the Kennedy family
to Columbia University thank you I'd
like to acknowledge some people who were
essential to the creation of Junkin who
are here today Doug Hughes the director
Andre bishop and Lincoln Center Theater
Stephen Pasquale Anika Boras Krystal
Steve Kline and resident boy genius
Alex Greenfield I am particularly moved
to be here today to celebrate drama
inspired by American history I love
history
it's endless richness its manifold
conundrums and on the occasion of
receiving this extraordinary award I
thought I might indulge and share some
thoughts about a formal conundrum which
motivated me to write junk I've long
been lon
I've long been taken by the
discrepancies between the dramaturgy of
story and the processes of history I
don't necessarily imply judgment in
acknowledging that we live in a time
where our awareness of the past
increasingly comes in the form of
entertainment of content sold to us in
one way or another for a few generations
this is meant the prestige picture in
Hollywood which morphed into a teaching
tool in the classroom now of course we
see the proliferation of historical
narrative in long-form television
purporting to convey the inner processes
of histories making of course we know
that narrative storytelling has its own
rules
the neurological function of human
identification mandates a single pole we
can attach to a protagonist through
whose eyes we can see and experience the
he'll this protagonist must of course
come up against an antagonist embodied
or abstract in the best stories it's
usually both and in our American version
of this timeless array we are usually
treated to the triumph of protagonist /
antagonist it isn't this hopeful
culmination of American narrative that
strikes me as discordant with history
though of course there is that no it's
fundamentally the notion that a single
individual his or her struggles his or
her subjectivity that these are somehow
the prime movers of the historical
process the implication is that a
society's moral dilemmas can be
summarized by a single consciousness
that one person's March or triumph March
to triumph or tragic defeat is actually
all that really needs to be known the
deeper message is of course that how we
feel about history matters more than
what we think about it I'm not sure
that's right I discovered two things in
my deep study of the financial history
of the 1980s first that the
organizational and philosophical basis
for our current political and civic
crises found their route in that era
second that no single point of view
could encompass the systemic changes
taking place
no single agent or intention was
actually responsible new ways of making
money bred new changes in the social
body fees started to go up the higher
the fees went the more incentives there
were to do deals the more deals the more
there was a need for deals this led to a
wholesale shift in what was
philosophically permissible a
redefinition of the National higher good
this is how and why it started to be
alright to prey on our own nation's
infrastructure as a way to feed the
system money was made legislation
followed yes the mercantile class was
rising to power and there were
consequences that flowed from that shift
of course now that we have a Salesman
I'll be out of snake oil in the Oval
office is not a coincidence and yet
the process itself was mostly blind
consequence provoking adaptation that
bred new consequence new adaptation how
to tell that story this is the question
I asked myself how to fracture a single
protagonist into a multiplicity of
driving forces how to transform
adaptation into driving action how to
dislodge the individual from the core
yet still offer the audience unnecessary
peg a single point of view without which
they might not be able to feel the
events taking place on stage before them
that was the formal challenge to try to
mirror more closely the impersonal
process of history in which subjectivity
is not operative but operated upon case
in point the for younger protagonists of
the play children of immigrants or
people of color all these characters are
seeking to change the world to make room
in it for folks like themselves money is
the means of that change but what ends
up being the real transformation sure at
the end of the play each of them has
found their place but in the process
money has gone from being a means to the
all-consuming end fidelity to nation has
taken a backseat to personal advancement
neither consequence was advocated nor
even intended and yet these are the
consequences far more decisive to our
contemporary history today thank you for
this extraordinary honor
[Applause]
so that's it we're done
thank you that was extraordinary thank
you so much for that and and to the
Kennedy family again
thank you I I'm really sad that the
Ambassador couldn't be with us today but
I'll call her tomorrow and tell her how
wonderful this was and we all owe Jeanne
an inexpressible debt of gratitude for
creating this prize and and she's
certainly with us in spirit today if
she's across town at the moment so
there's a reception afterwards outside
this room and thank you all for coming
good night
[Applause]